birthday with the white pieces to take
this to armageddon yeah and duda has
started with a transposition now into
the english opening the symmetrical
english opening duda i hope for his own
sake he didn't look and analyze the
previous game because actually one move
before he lost the previous game liam
blundered and duda could have fought his
way back he missed that opportunity and
okay we've gone into a symmetrical
position now we see this uh we've seen
this position a few times on the tour so
far a trader pawns and white bishop
coming out a quick trade there
very sensible play this is uh the tarash
variation now and uh magnus versus uh
yeah prague from yesterday isn't it same
same stuff exactly where prague lost
with the black pieces magnus endorsing
the white pieces in that game
and uh okay a slight change yesterday we
saw black's bishop move
and uh okay white's bishop retreating
this isolated pawn in the middle of the
board it's all about that guy that's
where the battle will revolve later
so far we haven't seen armageddon at all
this season right
just uh we've seen a few blitz tiebreaks
between duda and many players including
magnus carson last month for charity cup
but uh yeah armageddon would be fun
armageddon would be a lot of fun
duda he has to win this game to uh take
it to armageddon is this a very the
opening he's chosen is it very ambitious
i think it's nearly exactly the same as
the game prague against uh magnus from
from yesterday where prague actually got
a bit of an advantage uh but then got a
bit optimistic so following that that
same idea this night jump i remember
david pointed out and we could see it
happening again here so it's um yeah i
mean it's a good way to play uh for the
win with white pieces right yeah
slightly different move order maybe
giving black more options this time um
it feels like black's got a better
version of what prague had yesterday
for example the black bishop could enter
the center of the board right now
dude are shaking his head already
what is he unhappy about looks like a
standard position
as you guys mentioned the white knight
can jump into the f5 square but first
it's the black knight jumping into the
center
really nice post for it white's knight
on the edge of the board actually
attacked by black's queen now so it has
to retreat
yeah you don't really want to move the
knight back to that square i mean uh the
whole point of white's maneuver is to
move it to the more aggressive square
two squares forward from that uh but
there's there's clearly some issues with
that the queen coming out so a little
bit passive a little bit of a passive
retreat from duda who needs to win uh
this game uh but okay i mean it's a
blitz game yeah loads of time left so
and also white's advantage is not going
to run away all he has to do is uh just
focus on neutralizing the black
initiative so by
advantage i mean take a look at black's
isolated pawn in the middle of the board
he's got no friends
and uh that's going to be an issue yeah
and liam will try and compensate for the
fact that he does have this ugly
isolated pawn in the center of the board
by going active that's why the black
queen has aligned herself with the white
king
and uh okay duder just shuffling his
rook it definitely feels like dude mixed
up his move or during the opening he's
basically got a typical position just a
couple of moves down
uh so now
he's centralized all of black's pieces
look at the black pieces actually
they're all on pretty much their
ultimate squares the question is what to
do next
yeah it's so easy for duda to improve
either no i mean i i guess white would
like to make some exchanges of pieces
because that'll make the pawn in the
middle weaker so if you can go about
doing that get rid of black summer
black's dangerous pieces that would be
great but black's pieces are dangerous i
mean he'd love a light square bishop
okay he's making some progress over
there but there might be some attacking
possibilities that black can uh use a
bit later on in this position well
usually whenever i've played this type
of position and kind of made a little
bit of a mess of it you know i've just
tried to react to whatever black does
yeah and you know i don't necessarily
make any committal moves just simply
keep
on making small little moves like dude
has just played
yeah
and this is a very typical idea now uh
bringing the bishop back here uh
clearing it's out the way in some ways
now sometimes you can bring the black
queen to where that bishop was placed to
get it on that double power diagonal
creates some frets but uh the isolate
pawn's still there i mean just gotta try
to find a good plan here for duda to
make some peace exchanges i can't
see how that's easy to do at the moment
david any ideas i think mate i was about
to say maybe the only way to trade
pieces is to plant the knight in the
center of the board and that's what duda
is going for
if knights disappear bishops disappear
queens disappeared then blacks weakness
in the centre of the board that isolated
pawn in the middle for black will count
so dude knows exactly what he wants long
term but short term maybe some threats
against white's king i wouldn't be
surprised at some point if we do see
that idea simon not right now but
black's queen swinging across lining
itself with
lining the black queen and bishop up
together on the same diagonal first and
nitrate offered but on black's terms
this black knight if you don't capture
it now maybe it will jump in towards the
left side of the board some weaknesses
there for white i really don't like what
dude has done with the pawn structure
yeah the left side of the board that's
normally what we're told not to do again
we saw prague do this as well i mean
this is one of the
mistakes that maybe prague made against
magnus carson he actually uh did the
same advance with the same b pawn
leaving the same square week
and that knight that's just moved can
jump next to the white pawn which is now
a hold uh so it's strange that this
advance is very common but it's often a
mistake david just weakening squares
yeah i think it's just human nature you
think okay pawns further forward are
always better but you do leave
weaknesses behind and that's why dude
has paused right now down on the clock
under three minutes because you have to
trade a set of knights which he wanted
but he's activated black's bishop in the
process black's bishop now on a great
square black's knight also on a great
square
uh okay nice move though there uh by
duda improving the white queen it's also
getting ready to do the night back as
well oh i was getting carried away with
some night move there but i don't think
it works i'm always trying to keep an
eye out for any attacking possibilities
here but this is a much more sensible
move yeah liam is quite good in these
types of scenarios where he can just
kind of keep these one move ideas here
and there stop the opponent's plans he's
very good at stopping his opponents from
playing and this last queen move by
black lines up the queen and the black
bishop on the same diagonal pinning
white's knight and putting some pressure
uh there so
some tricks on the central uh central
lines the black rook's perfectly placed
dude has to be really careful he doesn't
fall for one of those tricks
he's playing very slowly dude uh two and
a half minutes now yeah but the the
problem with this type of position when
you're playing with the white pieces and
against the isolated porn is that you
have to be always mindful of
all of black's tricks because you make
one wrong move and that's it you're
busted so
i mean a move that i would be thinking
about
if it didn't lose on the spot is
actually just
nudging the rook the c1 rook one square
forward just to over protect the queen
yeah i can tell you've played these
positions before you bank because that's
the first move that came to my mind as
well dude i think has much less
experience in this type of position and
uh okay he's going active with his queen
that cost him a lot of time though he's
a minute and a half down on the clock
that's a significant time disadvantage
and where's that white queen going
it's not 100 clear maybe just stopping
the black rook from challenging for the
open file but this is the type of thing
you allow black's knight jumping in
attacking one of the white rooks and
coming to that square we mentioned
coming to that beautiful square and it's
there this is the one we mentioned that
if white hadn't moved the b pawn this
would never have been an issue so um
okay but you know
now you can get rid of the bishop you
can start making exchanges if you want
is black be why would you exchange off
that knight at this position you
wouldn't you wouldn't do it quite yet so
uh just keep improving position but hang
on a second liam only needs johnny's
draw
but that knight is just too good to
exchange for the bishop i think at the
moment the black knight
keep the black knight there white can
never get rid of the black knight now
and uh duda
i don't know sounding the tree it's not
great kind doesn't make a great
impression keeping pieces on though
that's what he's got to do he's going to
keep his many pieces on the board and
keep chances alive it's a blitz game uh
black i like this move he's trying to
gain some space on the king's side using
the pawn next to it next move the h pawn
to kick the queen away probably so it's
gaining space nearly always a good idea
well unless it weakens certain squares
yeah and i think we're going to see that
move next by liam kicking away the white
queen meanwhile i'm looking at the
bottom of the screen giri big advantage
for him right now can he put it in the
back of the net though he's he's he's
messed up a lot of chances when he's got
a big advantage so um yes
it's looking very very good for giri but
not over yet in that game uh meanwhile
the white queen kicked back to her
starting square this one is looking like
liam's doing very well but the question
is what next one beautiful night for
black
isn't quite enough yet to turn the game
on in his favor okay the black queen
switching sides
maybe focusing her attention now on the
queen side
maybe black wants to move a pawn on the
queen side uh just to try to get some
chances to uh open things up over on
that area uh and dude is just sort of
shuffling around at the moment there's
not much more comfort
yeah
he you know his positions just got worse
uh but he's
yeah but i mean even if liam were not to
make a single active move here and uh
speaking about an active move you know
retreating the bishop clearing the line
for the rook what is duda's plan
i think he's got to try i don't know
moving the knight swapping the bishops
and trying to gang up in that pawn but
it doesn't seem like it's uh gonna gonna
work greatly okay well liam's now moved
that night away from this great square
maybe just gonna keep going backwards
and forwards even and he has oh he only
needs a drawer
to win the match that's the second time
we've seen this position so dude i
cannot repeat moves uh now okay black
challenging for the open file duda put
his rook on a worse square just because
he has to play for the win so that's
interesting liam is going to try and
bully him with a thought of a draw uh in
order to worsen the white position and
okay a trade of rooks it's not clear who
that would help it's still not clear
what their plans are
another move i mean it's so strange
moving both your rooks away from the
open file it seems very very unnatural
that yeah but he does have an idea why
maybe he wants to push pawns on that
side
it feels like dude are definitely trying
to worsen his position but in order to
keep the pieces i mean the good thing
about duder's position which is always
the good thing is that white knight and
we haven't really talked about it in the
center of the board i remember uh
spassky said it was not the isolated
pawn which is the problem um it's the
square in front of it because you can
never attack that square so that white
knight can never be budged and you know
it really does
make a bit of a cement in the middle for
white to sort of move around and try
some ideas around and then the other
game yeah david the bar all the way over
to mom you are outside he turned around
lost control again
he does this he's doing it all the time
isn't he unbelievable lack of a killer
instinct for giri he's had many
opportunities in this tournament so far
but just putting the finishing touches
on it's deserted him completely yeah and
mama jaroff with a golden opportunity to
take that match but i see mama jarov has
he made a move now with uh 13 seconds on
the clock gary more than a minute on the
clock that means the position is just
wild
and uh yeah and uh talking about wild
well looking at the clock times this
position is going to get crazy because
both players you know don't have much
time and they're just maneuvering and
it's so tense
yeah incredibly tense this one i mean
nothing much has changed over the last
five ten moves but uh it will come down
to a bit of a time scramble maybe duda's
best shot here is to just maneuver
around forever gain a time advantage and
then take a big risk uh meanwhile it
does look like shaq has found the
winning move with only a few seconds
left on his clock
gary's struggling for his life
oh okay this game though still
black's rook coming in now damn doing
well but
do you think he's gonna get it do you
think he's gonna get the draw
no i um well i do think liam is gonna
get the draw his position looks to me a
little like it's overwhelming but uh
okay this is a great idea doubling rooks
on the sea line and once again
there's no active plan for duda
everything has a consequence
but he's still got that knight in the
middle and he's got his rooks and a
better square he's got his bishop on a
better square you know those white rooks
were very badly placed and what happens
on the bar
oh well wow maybe there was a trick in
the position uh it wasn't entirely clear
why the evaluation bar reacted so much
it still looks completely level to me or
at least balanced uh balanced chances
and okay black's queen placed herself on
a bit of an odd square in the center of
the board
eyed up by the white bishop but no way
for the white knight to jump out of the
way safely right now white's bishop is
undefended so i'm expecting duder to
move it or protect it such a tense game
i mean not not much is really happening
but
it's gonna they're just getting shorter
of time 30 seconds we have a result in
the other game we have a result oh and
it's another devastating loss for anish
giri losing here game two means he loses
the match
great win for shakira and mamadiarov our
favorite entertainment entertainer he
has pulled off a great win in the second
blitz game to win the match
and meanwhile no progress at all in this
game the queens are just moving back and
forth duda is completely at a loss for a
plan he has
made zero progress and likewise liam
just bring the queen back and forth back
and forth and finally the white pawn
commits and kicks away the black knight
but that weakens white's position
okay dude he had to do it at some point
he's just playing on liam's nerves now
the black knight will retreat i quite
like this i mean if you go rook d2 which
is played
now at last he's ready to move that
knight unleash the bishop so it does
seem like dude is finding some harmony
in his position here by he's got his
pieces to pretty decent squares now yeah
i i just i'm surprised liam kind of took
his night away from that square we were
praising so much earlier i think maybe
he's regretting that and we'll try and
rearrange for the black knight to get to
an active square
meanwhile duda creating a big big threat
actually white's knight wants to jump to
the f5 square starting to create some
threats against the black king liam has
to be really careful now this white
queen just sneaky uh sneakily trying to
create those attacks both under 30
seconds and it's really really tense now
and uh well he's going for the attack
with f4 as well he's definitely
committing and that idea is still in the
air you know now the white knight can
jump to the f5 square but he's pushed
the pawn
now the fireworks starts when both sides
have just over 20 seconds on the clock
the birthday boy trying to create a real
attack and liam's trying to shut the
door in his face he's trying to force
the queens off the board if the queens
disappear black is doing okay and uh we
just saw trader pawns there
queen trade or no queen trade i think
you have to exchange queens i don't want
to but what else can i play here
anything i mean
queen i mean
i think he had to play this and uh you
know he can he still got that knight but
it's it's just you know it's the same
thing going on here uh they have to
maneuver about but now this end game
kind of it feels like black is okay
black's certainly okay i mean i think it
i think it's just rarely been equal most
of the way through pretty much this game
that night also coming back to one of
the good squares the bishop stepping out
the way of a night jump and here it
comes it coming back to it it's gone all
the way around the board hasn't it that
night but it's going to find its home
again
and white making some exchanges
very tense very tense and blacks rooks
are getting active
and all black needs to do is to bring
the black king into the game and i think
he will be safe oh the position repeats
itself once there dude can't take the
draw though look at the white rooks they
are such sad pieces and the black knight
is coming in for the kill
going for some pawns
and everything is pointing towards e3
porn it falls off the board okay still a
lot of danger for the black king looking
very good now for liam lido he has won a
pawn his piece is very nicely
centralized the only slight danger is
the black king if white can somehow get
the other rook around to attack that
king but it seems very safe the black
king at the moment okay here comes the
rook but where's it going uh liam lee
looking big favorite at the moment
what's happening with the uh doodle's
clock
it looks like he had a couple of seconds
left with just a small delay there but
uh oh dude in big trouble about to get
checkmated is he and now there's going
to be a four ah that's the end i think
over four
duda
he loses the match to liam in blitz tie
breaks